willkommen bei sofora was kann ich für
dich tun ich weiß ganz ehrlich nicht
warum ich schon wieder so im rollenspiel
modus bin aber hallo herzlich willkommen
waren willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender testvideo in letzten
beauty adventskalender habe ich mit
meiner wunderbaren assistentin kelly
ausgepackt diesen werde ich mal wieder
alleine testen gibt es den wunderschönen
adventskalender von sofora und jetzt
alle zusammen dieses videos nicht
gesponsert ich habe keinen kontakt zu
erfahren ich wurde nicht bezahlt und der
wurde mir auch nicht gerade zugeschickt
ich habe meine pin onsen dafür
hingeblättert und ich kann euch sagen
die erste eindruck ist wirklich
wunderbar also ich mag dieses gold blaue
sehr gerne
ich habe auch mal gehört und dann müsst
ihr mir vielleicht mal was sagen es gibt
leute die ihre weihnachts deko jedes
jahr neu entscheiden zum beispiel sagen
sie ja dieses mal wird alles gold rot
oder gold blau oder weiß silber eine
frage hätte ich da aber an diese leute
wie bezahlt ihr das doch bevor wir
anfangen gucken wir mal nach dem preis
der favorite adventskalender den ich
hier habe kostet 109 euro also zehn euro
mehr als der klasse box adventskalender
da bin ich ja mal gespannt ich liebe das
gold aber auch sagen ich bin voll auf
dem gold trip und ich weiß nicht mal
woher das plötzlich kommt aber ich liebe
plötzlich gold
ist etwas gold finde ich schön so ist es
auch mit diesem update für den
wunderschön
es gibt sogar 25 türchen also musste
vielleicht aus der uk sein und auf der
verpackung stand das sogar und ich finde
das auch das ist ein richtig guter
adventskalender zum wiederverwenden und
wie immer ab trommelwirbel fangen wir an
mit den kirchen nummer eins und fakten
jetzt alles mal aus es ist ja verlangt
das ultra dosierung vitamin c und
produziert in frankreich das klingt
immer schon ganz gut wo ich lasse mich
von so was auch immer ich beeindrucken
weil sowas sieht schön schön aus also
jeden morgen aus saubere trockene
gesicht es riecht sehr schön und vitamin
c ist doch immer gut war anscheinend ist
der kartoffel und sonnenblumen drin
dieses serum preise für ihren und einen
schein fürs gesicht geben meines immer
gut was ich aufs gesicht zu packen
wir sind pflege tut uns einmal gut wie
zimmer vielleicht jetzt die preise
zusammen bei dem produkt sind wir schon
bei 19 eur 99 und welche kandidaten
verbirgt sich hinter natürlich in nummer
zwei super globe
die wollen dass wir global sind extrem
schein christ highlighting packung sieht
sehr stylisch aus super-g highlight
ich muss sagen ich habe jetzt natürlich
schon viele highlighter so sieht das auf
dem finger heraus was ich an dem
highlighter mag ist dass es so ein
kühles gold ist also goldig aber so weiß
gold jetzt interessiert mich echt mal
der preis 30 euro 95 was ist mit diesen
beauty adventskalendern los warum machen
wieder so teure produkte seien zehn
gramm wie viel drin 4 gramm ja okay okay
okay okay okay das ist eine kleinere
größe die sind vier gramm also die
hälfte ungefähr immer noch ungefähr 5 10
euro 15 euro tragen jetzt hier natürlich
nummer drei verbirgt sich ein statisch
werdich verlosen kennt ihr diese marke
wenn ich mit dieser marke auskennt könnt
ihr sie empfehlen
oha das richtig gut
der geruch wechsel zwischen wall street
mega gut und dieses shampoo kostet 8
euro 95 nummer vier sitzen sie aber die
kranken marken raus to face to be
perfect ein setting pauser gemischt mit
für sich und zeigen mich das werde ich
jetzt nicht ausprobieren das packe ich
auf jeden fall in die verlosungs kiste
mit rein wenn ihr beim einer verlosung
mitmachen wollt die bald stattfinden
dann folgt mir einfach auf instagram und
dort werde ich dann posten und dann
könnt ihr dokumentieren und so könnt ihr
was gewinnen also muss ich sagen die
verpackung ist wirklich schwer ist es
ist die travel sich leute dieser
adventskalender ist einfach zu krass die
nummer fünf ist ganz klein aber der
inhalt ist riesengroß und zwar haben wir
was ist da drin
wir sind ihr lese zuerst markt gay cops
und jetzt gucken wir was die marc jacobs
lifting mascara kostet die normale größe
kostet 27 euro 95 das ist ja nicht die
normale größe
das ist 28 gramm okay das ist weil das
ist die probier größe das bedeutet das
wird halt nicht 27 95 kosten
aber ich würde mal schätzen dass es ein
drittel von der größe also machen wir
geteilt durch 3 und mit wer zehn euro
die backe ich glaube ich auch zum
verlosen das 24 türchen hat und
wahrscheinlich kein nikolaus gibt gucken
wir trotzdem voller erwartungen in
türchen nummer 6 und hoffen dass etwas
drin ist ja okay das mixed bestürzt ist
was ist retinol tonic ich kenne retinol
sehr um das soll anscheinend die poren
sehr verfeinern hier steht auch snooping
trauner das weiche haut das bedeutet ja
ebenmäßig und glatt und nicht mit so
koren
die poren hast sie das auch so wenn
menschen aussehen die menschen und poren
haben ekelhaft aber so ein toner ist
immer gut sooo gut vier euro
das ist wirklich nicht das ist eine
probier größe das ist kein
nikolausgeschenk da können wir uns
eigentlich seien aber durch die nummer 7
wird wieder super klassen und zwar haben
wir einen alleine ein double eyeliner
eine seite sieht so aus die andere seite
kann man so raus drehen und das ist dann
eher miesen kohlestift das ist wie
nicoletta ist immer mit den liebhabern
sagt jetzt weiß ich dass er am besten
performt und jeden eyeliner den ich
jetzt danach benutzen werde wird nicht
mit diesem eyeliner mithalten können
damals benutzt habe 295 und der ist hier
einfach so drin türchen nummer sleeping
maske hat lavendel drin und das ding ist
lavendel wenn man das riecht gibt es
einen beruhigenden effekt und ich kann
mir das richtig gut vorstellen dass man
sich abends so eine lavendel maske ins
gesicht schmiert diese probier größe
würde eigentlich theoretisch sieben euro
kosten das ist auch schon wieder
verrückt und jetzt kommt meine
lieblingszahl türchen nummer 9 ohne ja
mittelfeld christoph robin aloe vera das
ist eine kopfhaut maske sehr gut winter
bekommt man nämlich trockene kopfhaut
von der heizungsluft da sollte man sowas
denken 11 euro würde diese grobe kosten
nummer 4 der saison
lipgloss ich glaube dass verlose ich
ganz ehrlich auch weil ich habe viele
lippen produkte und das wäre irgendwie
verschwenderisch wenn ich denn jetzt
aufmachen weil man ihn danach nicht mehr
verschenken kann
99 hier lacht ja mein einhorn herz ich
halte mich mache sie so schön aus hand
cleansing gel
es macht jetzt die hände sauber aber
nichts mit desinfektionsmittel
verwechseln es kommt als ein geh raus
und wird auf der hand sehr flüssig ja
gut so viel zwischendurch finde ich das
echt gar nicht mal so schlecht und
leider muss ich sagen gewisser packung
und dieses glitzer sage man jetzt mit
eurer freundin im café dann hat sie so
aus ihrer handtasche und sie dann so
gläsernes vanille duften dass hunt der
aus stürzt sich das einmal kurz auf dem
redet auch weiter mit mir und sagt wenn
die haare habe ich das noch gar nicht
gesehen was hat er dann gesagt sieht
einfach aus als ob jemand sein leben im
griff hat also ungefähr drei euro kostet
dieses handke aber jetzt das ist gut
weil am anfang hat man noch so ein
bisschen so negatives gefühl gehabt aber
jetzt fühlen sich die hände einfach nur
sauber an mit sauberen händen öffne ich
jetzt türchen nummer 12
ich entschuldige mich für diese
unprofessionelle und nicht neutrale
reaktionsprodukte benefit
[Musik]
ok sorry ich hab mir einen bobby brown
augenbrauen bürsten dingens gekauft für
wie geld und ich habe ein paar mal
benutzt und irgendwann ist mir
aufgefallen das ist eine falsche farbe
das ist auch nicht so gut na ja und
jetzt wollte ich mich noch mal geld
dafür ausgeben aber hier ist ein gel
damit kämpft ihr euch einfach die
augenbrauen durch und dann bleiben die
sonne sind ein bisschen buschiger 2020
ist das jahr der buschigen augenbrauen
na ja und das ja von ihr wisst schon
endlich endlich endlich wieder ein
unterschied wird aber in meinem herzen
sichern unterschied also die
originalgröße davon kostet 24 euro 95
ganz schön viel geld 100 milliliter von
diesem produkt würden 356 euro kosten
seine probier größe was sagen würden wir
sagen wieder ein drittel sagen wieder
irgendwas bei 8 euro nennt ganz probier
größen jens triebel size natürlich 13
kusch mascara von milch ab jetzt seit
neuesten milch foundation und browns da
das mache ich dann hier so in die saiten
rasch damit sagte zu den männern
couscous
ich habe so viel zeit mit meinem vater
verbracht ich habe jobs okay ich hätte
vielleicht nicht schon mascara drauf
haben sollen aber meine laienhaft das
auge sagt stabil aber wieder eine kleine
größe
das müssen wir im kopf behalten weiter
geht es mit der 14
[Musik]
ich kenne die marke irgendwo her was
kannst du fast alle hauttypen soja
gesicht seife deutsch klingt so viel und
cooler nachgesagt jetzt weiß ich woher
mir diese marke bekannte ich habe in new
york als ich in new york war so ein
sanftes zucker gesichts peeling von
dieser marke kauft 15 euro 95 für diese
tube und falls ihr damit erfahrungen
habt schreibt gerne in die kommentare
115 hier haben wir sehr gut eine creme
für die augenringe das finde ich sehr
gut drei milliliter sind ganz der tue
die zehn milliliter größe kostet 32 euro
das ist drei also ein drittel ungefähr
also sind wir hier bei dieser kleinen
größe sogar bei 10 euro nummer 60 immer
genäht iglu - ein keller könne man
gnädig nominelle spitze für nutzte ich
habe tatsächlich so einen ähnlichen aber
nicht in bronze sondern in so einem
silber ton und deswegen benutze ich die
nicht so gerne aber in bronze wenn ich
den gerne benutzt
es gibt so ein schimmer dass es mit
lidschatten nur als cremiger stick reden
können wir aber vielen jetzt können wir
zum praxistest seid ihr eigentlich bei
lidschatten team matt oder team scheine
ich und auf jeden fall team scheint was
würdest du mich im echten leben kosten
22 euro 95 gewinne gewinne gewinne
weiter geht's mit werden
17 wenn wir sie dann mal finden und dann
können wir sie aus packen hier ist die
nummer 17 ist ein großes produkt
cleanskin care sie dann tonart und einer
also nachdem ihr gesicht gewaschen hat
mit gesichts reiniger dann könnt ihr in
wattepads nehmen oder ein baumwoll pad
unter dem geht es und macht noch mal so
schön mit 100 milliliter sieht mir das
aber nach einer normalen größe aus die
preise 12 eur 78 dass teenager habe ich
schon bei den clearasil produkten gemein
nummer 18 kommt nicht voran um 18 gibt
ische magie purpose skin cream das sieht
aus wie vaseline fühlt sich sehr ähnlich
ankommen sauberen fingern so es ist 100
prozent natürlich mit honig und olivenöl
magic dream mehrzweck hautcreme kostet
17 euro 95 für 30 milliliter das sind 75
ja sagen wir
euro also meine lippen fühlen sich
tatsächlich sehr gut an ich würde jetzt
aber nicht auf meinem gesicht schmieren
ich halte generell sehr weit entfernt
von meinem gesicht leicht auf trockene
stellen auf meine lippen auf meine
ellenbogen aber dafür ist glaube ich ein
bisschen zu teuer ja das ist meine
gesichtscreme eine augencreme da ist mir
eine ellbogen creme und diese kriegen
benutze ich für meine kniekehlen das hat
alles einen sinn
man sagt ja immer wenn jetzt aus dem
mittelalter jemand hierher reisen würde
was würde zur technologie sagen aber ich
denke mir wenn jemand aus dem
mittelalter hierher reisen würde würde
sagen gäbe ist das denn alles in daran
beim badezimmer ich weiß nicht ob sie
damals badezimmer hat man kläre mal
jemanden aus dem mittelalter die ganzen
produkte die du für deinen körper
benutzt erklärt einen menschen aus dem
mittelalter ein adventskalender haben
sie gesellschaft ist so konsum geil
geworden dass wir nicht mal zum konsum
tag weihnachten warten können wir müssen
jeden tag konsumieren dass wir auf
diesen konsum tag warten die nummer 19
ich meine über den preis bauen wir gar
nicht sprechen
der wurde wieder reingeholt aber jetzt
kommen so produkte wo ich nlg boosting
creme ich habe das gefühl jetzt packen
sie diese produkte rein die so kommt
normalerweise die hübschen cream und dj
scream und hier haben wir origins sinkt
wie intensive feuchtigkeitspflege mit
energie kardinal größe 31 euro ich würde
sechs euro sein darf man viele
verschiedene feuchtigkeitscreme
eigentlich benutzt wenn es jetzt mal so
ein haut spezialisten unter euch gibt
könnt ihr das vielleicht mal den
kommentaren erklären der welt kalenders
und seine trend ist gekommen jetzt sind
wir auch im endspurt und türchen nummer
20 hat
alles kennen wir irgendwie alle oder ich
hab das gefühl das kennt man auch von
urban outfitters mario barth diskus
gesicht spray mit aloe vera kräuter und
rosenwasser das kann man für
zwischendurch benutzen um sein gesicht
zu integrieren ich weiß aber jetzt nicht
wie es mit make-up ist es riechen meine
esoterik produkte ich fühle mich einfach
entspannt und wohl gar nicht so teuer
also diese größe kostet jetzt vier euro
50 weil sofort legt man die doppelte
größe und die kostet 8 euro 95 also ist
ok
[Musik]
21.21 auf die größe kommt es nicht an
leute mir was kleine ihr dürft zuerst
gucken das sind wieder so augen masten
mit cannabis man bekommt sie bei so vor
als fünfer pack für 13 euro 95 das heißt
eine so eine packung kostet drei euro
ist schon krass dass man soviel seine
schönheit ausgeben kann ist eigentlich
auch ein verbrechen oder 22 ist eine
ganz ganz kleine tube einem eustress
krems eines meisters war warum ist diese
probe so klein am berg muss euch sagen
das wird nicht gezeigt gut das ist
wirklich eine klitzekleine probe da
würde ich jetzt null euro für berechnen
23 uhr haben wir wieder mängel waren
jetzt schon ganz schön viele fähige
produkte oder schwanz lösen setting
potter wieder ein setting kauder
ich denke mal das will ich wieder
verlosen weil ich habe wirklich sehr
viele setting borders das kostet 14 euro
nicht schlecht herr specht kommen wir
zur weihnachts türchen blome 24 wir
haben ja das 25 natürlich in deswegen
nicht so spektakulär denke ich drei
mascara
also preis leistung stimmt absolut aber
ein bisschen
komische auswahl von produkten durch ist
die originalgröße es mir leid ich muss
diese preise aber in genau dieser
tonlage sagen weil ich es nicht glauben
kann
36 eur 95 main sieht aus wie normale
mascara und ich denke mal maybelline tut
ihren job aber denkmal für 36 euro von
90 wird sie ganz gut sein es gibt nur
eine bewertung krise mascara schenk
lange dramatische wimpern hält ziemlich
lange und trimet nicht man muss nur
aufpassen da sie relativ schnell
austrocknet letztes türchen nummer 25
weil das ja tatsächlich der erste
richtige weihnachtstag ist und in uk
viel mehr wert ist was erwartet uns da
eine lidschatten palette länder beauty
nur skandale aber nicht mein bruder
beauty so eine schlechte mag ist aber
irgendwie sind die immer in skandale
verwickelt mit reggae star und wem auch
sonst es ist die obsession kleine bevor
ich mir die farben angucken möchte ich
wissen auf was für einer preisliga wir
uns hier befinden 29 eur 95 also für 30
euro noch mal eine palette und der
mascara davor war einfach noch mal viel
mehr wert weil die bereit für den ruby
von dieser wunderschönen palette ich
liebe die bahn die haben auch alle so
einen goldenen schimmer tun gehabt ich
werde diese palette lieben ich weiß es
jetzt schon
ich liebe mein gott okay ich bin ich bin
wirklich ich bin ich bin verliebt in
diese palette tolles letztes türchen die
haben ja relativ am anfang schon gemerkt
dass dieser adventskalender auf jeden
fall seien preiswert ist und hier werde
den gesamtwert dieses adventskalenders
das ist ganz schön viel das lohnt sich
es waren wirklich viele gute produkte
drin ich bin sehr begeistert von diesem
adventskalender
das ist dreimal mascara drin gehabt was
ja okay und ein bisschen viele
pflegeprodukte finde ich einen test für
dieses video habe ich noch und zwar
sollen bei diesem huder beautyprodukten
die rote farbe so schlecht rausgehen und
jetzt rasch marcus meyn hände
die angst war um so an das ist ganz gut
raus gegangen außer hier beim finger
aber da habe ich halt zu kurz gewaschen
also alles gut bis zum nächsten
adventskalender auspackt video bis
dienstag als sie bei verlosung mitmachen
wollt bald gibt es bestimmt los
[Musik]